on est vraiment dans votre élément lise
dion sur scène quelques heures avant
début de votre spectacle
est-ce que vous avez un rituel comment
vous sentez nerveuse quand ça se passait
très très calculée à rémy tests de son
c'est un maquillage que 7 45 7 45
vêtements micro puis le reste parlé à
mes amis personnes décédées un peu
derrière le rideau et après 30 ans et
vous parlez à vos personnes décédées oui
oui c'est que presque tout le monde
qu'ils étaient près de ma famille sont
décédés mais je tends pas unique mais
j'ai des bons amis qui sont partis aussi
fait je leur parle un peu avant chose la
demande de me donner de la mémoire de
l'énergie de la présence puis à date
limande ça fonctionne pas peur parce que
oui j'ai l'impression que ça fonctionne
mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est ma
croyance à - puis j croate ina c'est
comme ça
mais laquelle je vous en parle je trouve
ma bru à irait bien que mon jean votre
nouveau spectacle s'intitule jeu rendues
justement vous êtes conduit plus dire
tout le monde vous aime tout le monde
sans nous connaître
mais vous êtes radio jeu rendues dans la
même place que mon public dans le sens
qu'il ya des choses qui ont pu perdre
notre temps avec ça il ya des des choses
sans importance fait au monde où je
tente plus d'un bac pour ce ça me tente
plus de faire ça je suis sereine je suis
en pleine capacité type de goûter de
gemmes vieillit pour ce cellphone le
reste ça c'est moins drôle pour la
patience pour la b si pour l'heure mais
on voit bien où la femme en avant ou la
forme d'un mariage justement que les
deux fait pipi la patience âgées place
yang jiechi coach et de la ns a vraiment
faut que je me parle régulièrement pour
pour tramontane faire gardien il n'y a
pas de feu l'on va se calmer l affaire
d'état
tout a été mangée il ya quelques
semaines j'ai rencontré votre ami yvon
des gens là qui me faisait écouter on
peut plus dire un humour ce qu'on disait
il ya 30 ans parce que je suis déjà
quand même commandant québécois il ya
l'autoroute est ouest d'accord d'accord
avec ça qu'on peut pas dire on peut plus
dire j'avais même un numéro et que
j'avais écrit pour il ya eu la femme
afghane que je pourrais pas pu refaire
mais bien et il ya des numéros j'avais
pensé avec des accents italiens arabes
mais je n'ai pas faire parce que je n'ai
pas blessé personne puis je voulais
c'est trop dangereux la ligne c'est le
racisme on fait quand il ya raison
monsieur deschamps peut pas on peut pas
faire ce qu'on faisait ya des années
c'est sûr vous me voyez venir maicon
oui c'est revenons à l'actualité
récemment c'est le garder a dit on a
peut être parlé d'ailleurs dimanche au
gala des olivier que pensez vous de ce
sketch est là mais j'étais voir le
spectacle de mike ward et je connais
michael puis je sais que c'est un être
extrêmement sensible peut le faire
pleurer comme ça même si à l'aide d'un
bourg hull
je trouve ça dur pour lui mais en même
temps il y des propos qui sont dures à
suivre des fois tu
et donc pour y est allé un peu trop loin
d'ottawa je trouve qui est allé un peu
trop loin
puis je peux lui dire à lui le fameux
dérange pas il me connaît depuis deux
mois j'ai c'est pas mon genre de mots
mais en même temps quand je regarde son
spectacle je te le dis que j'ai ri
beaucoup moins les faces b you quand je
me suis retourné à mêmes caméras
surveillant il vous reste deux ans votre
retour après est-ce que vous êtes déjà
rendu à l'après ou pas du tout c'est à
dire que je pense à des projets c'est
ceux d'autres projets d'écriture le
j'essaye de voir les aux rapports entre
l école de cinéma pour parce que le
premier livre que j'écris sur mama
j'aimerais vraiment seconde qu'on fasse
un film avec puis je vais aller à
l'école de cinéma pour d'abord qui me
monte à écrire le script comme fou parce
que il créera en libye inscriptions pour
la même chose du tout et puis
m'imprégner du langage de cinéma pour
comprendre mieux le projet puis avoir
une idée d'ensemble comment ça pourrait
soit même si c'est pas moi qu'ils
réalisent met au courant de comment ça
se passe je suis très excité de retourne
à l'école la main lésions bonne rentrée
scolaire
merci
[Rires]